yes sure fantastic well good evening
everybody and
uh welcome to uh the first meeting of
health scrutiny committee this
new municipal year and obviously i'd
like to welcome everyone to the meeting
but especially
any new members to the committee uh
really pleased that you've come to join
us
and also like to say thank you to all
the officers who come here this evening
to either present reports or to answer
questions we really do
appreciate the time that you're giving
to us thank you so much and so this is
an informal
meeting of committee uh but we're still
as you know
uh being recorded and so obviously it's
very important everyone can be heard
really really clearly so
if you aren't speaking could i just ask
that you put your microphones onto mutes
just so that
there isn't any background noise that
would be really really helpful
and if you do want to ask a question at
any stage that's absolutely great
but please could you perhaps let me know
in the chat i will be
checking the chat regularly and
obviously we'll make sure that
everyone asks the questions that they
would like which helps me to kind of
order the sequence of that
so with that said perhaps we can just
start with the agenda items
and agenda item one was to note
attendances
i just received um apologies from
counselor dr carr
i don't think we're missing anybody else
are we oh that's fantastic okay so
we know councillor dr cars uh apologies
and accept them of course
and then agenda item two is membership
of the committee including chairman
and vice chair so um as uh your chairman
and uh councillor taylor as your vice
chair you're
happy to accept those those
recommendations and that you're happy
with the committee structure and assume
that everyone is happy with that agenda
item
fantastic brilliant okay so gender item
3 is just the terms of reference again
really just for us to make sure that
we're happy to accept those
they've been detailed in our report is
anything anyone would like to question
about those
no questions all clear that's that's
great thank you so much okay so item
four is declarations of interest and we
do usually have one or two people would
like to make a declaration so
yes councillor lloyd
um i'm a trustee of trump and domestic
abuse services which i know is
mentioned that domestic abuse has
mentioned in the agenda papers
thank you thank you council lloyd
councillor taylor
i'm an nhs worker councillor berkeley
okay fantastic
councillor weston
i also work for the nhs chair okay
we just about caught that councilor
weston i'm not sure is your mic okay
sorry i i work for the nhs fantastic
thank you so much does anybody else
would like to
um mention the declaration raise a
declaration there okay
fantastic okay thank you so much for
that so uh moving on to um agenda item
five
which was the minutes of the last
meeting and we held those in march
and is everybody happy to accept that
they were a correct record of our
meeting
okay that's fantastic thank you so much
okay so
agenda item six is questions from the
public i don't think we've received any
on this occasion have we
no so and no okay so we can move on to
um agenda item seven
which is an update on trafford together
the locality plan it's the new locality
plan
and just before we um introduce our
offices to this report
just wanted to say that the committee
does recognize obviously the huge amount
of work that's already gone on
in integrating our care services up to
this point
and the reason that we felt it was a
really important item to bring
to committee this time is that we know
that there are
um legislative changes coming forward
that there is massive restructuring
in the way that we actually bring about
integration it is an incredibly complex
area and i think you know as we've read
the reports i think we all realize that
this is a huge undertaking
it's also being undertaken very very
quickly indeed
and so i just wondered as officers
present their report to us
if they could perhaps simplify the
changes that are going to happen just so
that we all have a really good
understanding as much as we can at this
point because i know and it's kind of
learned learning a lot
in a short space of time but kind of
understanding of what those changes mean
in terms of governance and obviously
also what the changes mean for our
residents how is this going to
actually improve things for our
residents how is it going to reduce the
inequalities
that we know have been really ruthlessly
exposed by the pandemic
and and how residents will actually have
an input into all of this
because obviously as a health scrutiny
committee we are really anxious that
there's a democratic element to this as
well
so and i'd just like to say thank you to
the officers who are presenting the
report tonight
and i think do we have emma emma brown
with us
is it emma that's going to be presenting
um
it's um i'm just going to do a very
short introduction and
uh sarah radcliffe will also join me in
that and then emma and
uh tom maloney will help us and support
any questions from the committee that's
okay
that's absolutely fine and members
obviously please do raise any questions
that you have
and with me and um you know we will just
want to find out as much as we possibly
can
about this piece of work that's going to
have massive implications for our
residents so thank you over to you diane
thank you
lovely thank you very much
and thank you members for inviting us
tonight to update you on
both the traffic locality plan
developments
and the changes and which are very
significant for the nhs
commissioning structures uh going
forward i'm just going to spend a few
minutes
very quickly pulling out a couple of
points around the locality plan
implementation
and then hand over to sarah radcliff to
talk you through some of the
changes that we the council barclays as
described there for you
so as you know the locality plan was in
its infancy as we um
hit the pandemic really so some aspects
of the work had to be paused however
quite a lot of the work was accelerated
by
the approaches that we talked by working
in collaboration
across health and social care and with
our voluntary sector colleagues
and our communities and really
emphasizing the
multi-disciplinary neighborhood working
and how that kicked in to support
everybody and through this what has been
a very difficult period
and we have implemented a new
neighborhood-based home care service as
a really good example of driving change
through
and to support care closer to home
enable a wider group of staffing to be
employed and
reduce carbon footprint by and enabling
people to be recruited more locally
we've supported and our colleagues in
the hospital to ensure that people have
been
unable to go home as fast as possible in
the safest way with the right support
through a various uh discharge pathways
and discharge recessed beds which we
have talked uh
talked uh kennedy through before we've
worked together across greater
manchester as well as locally around
supported discharge processes
around um work with our uh medical
uh colleagues to have digital solutions
for primary care
to see people um even during uh the
situations in lockdown
and and we've launched a new
safeguarding hub in social care which
ensures people get to speak quickly when
they need help
with something that may have gone wrong
and we've also
implemented clinical access services and
to support our ambulance service
and our primary care colleagues and our
hospitals to see
people quickly and in the right places
and that's just pulling a couple of
things out of that very long list that
we've given you there of some of the
work that we've done
and the reflections that we brought into
and the pandemic scrutiny a few months
ago
around some of the learning from kobe
she's now being
in included in a locality plan refresh
which is underway
and tom maloney is leading that and and
we will
we will be able to bring that back into
scrutiny at a later date but we're
really clear that we want to take some
of the positives
and a lot of the learning through into a
refreshed locality as we move forward
and this is all at the backdrop of a
very significant health
and nhs change which
as councillor barclay pointed out we are
now in in the process of implementing
and i'm going to hand over to my
colleagues our right click now to take
you through that detail
thank you diane so um thank you
councillor barkley i'll
quite quickly take you through the
national reorganization of the nhs as a
as quickly as i can really and then
obviously colleagues
such as emma and tom have been working
you know to make this all happen
just to say from the very beginning that
this reorganization for trafford is
absolutely
done in the context of the locality plan
so
we are keeping to those principles of
working for the people of trafford
working in our place which is trafford
and its neighborhoods and working with
our partners
so the locality plan binds all this
together as we go through this
reorganization
and obviously it's a journey we've been
on in greater manchester probably
from around 2015 with devolution but
specifically in trafford we're building
on things that we've done in the last
three years
so around won the locality plan but also
our local care alliance which i know
we've talked to you about before where
all of our providers in health and
social care
come together to work together for
trafford
the fact that we've moved community
services into trafford so the trafford
local care organization
which becomes a real foundation for us
to build on and our joint commissioning
board which members
have been involved in across both the
council and the ccg
so we've got a foundation for these um
these changes but the white paper came
in february it goes to the house of
commons in june
and what it actually means is that the
healthcare system in england completely
reorganizes
what we will have is the biggest change
in two decades as far as
commissioning is concerned as there will
no longer
be a local statutory commissioning
organization
in boroughs like trafford so from
april next year what we will have is a
greater manchester
integrated care system which will be the
statutory nhs system
money will flow into that not into ccgs
as it does
at the moment and then out into our
provider
colleagues our nhs provider colleagues
um that will mean that the ccgs in
england will all be disestablished
obviously that means trafford ccg will
cease to exist at that point
all the functions that we have will move
to the ics
in terms of that from trafford and all
the staff below board level will be
employed by
the integrated care system of greatest
manchester
um it is our understanding and what
we're working to that those staff will
then be deployed
back into trafford local organizations
so that we don't lose any of the skills
or knowledge or expertise that we've
built
up in working with partnership to
actually deliver the locality plan and
other things as we move
forward so we are basing this around
trafford as our place that's really
important in the white paper it's a real
tenant of what has come out
and all of our commissioning functions
that knowledge that expertise
will be aligned with and work within
um providers and aligned with our
council as we do at the moment but
through the statutory
ics of greater manchester in terms of
doing that
on the ground what it will look like
when we haven't got a
ccg in place there will be three main
parts really for trafford
there will be a locality board which
we're calling our one system board
and that will build upon the joint
commissioning board we have but it will
have
our providers on um health watcher on
we've already initiated that board
established that board in
shadow form and it is being co-chaired
at the moment by the leader of council
and the chair of the ccg so that's
already been established and that will
be the board that will
take the strategic lead on ensuring the
delivery of health and social care
for trafford and they'll also be a place
leader
in each of the 10 localities of greater
manchester
and that leader will be accountable to
greater manchester's integrated care
system
but they will have the lead delegated
authority
for trafford in in that way in terms of
doing that
we'll also be in each locality of
provider collaborative so we will build
upon our local care alliance and all the
partnerships we've had and that will be
about providers working together
to deliver the locality plans for their
residents
and there will be a engine room is what
we're calling it at the moment
of clinical and practitioner leadership
and emma who's here tonight has taken
quite a big lead in that for traffic as
well
so we've got a whole programme of work
underway for that tom has been
instrumental in leading that for us over
the last few months
i think we're confident that we can get
to april and ensure that we're still
delivering the locality
plan but it is a huge change for
colleagues
um both within the ccg but also
colleagues who we work with in
partnership
across the council and other
organizations
so that's just a five minute summary
of the major changes council of barclay
but obviously
happy for tom and emma and diane or
myself to answer any questions as best
we can
thank you thank you very much that was
really really helpful and it has helped
me understand i hope it's helped um
other
members of committee to understand
things are there any questions at this
point for
either diane or sarah
councillor taylor
sorry council but i think there are
people who've requested to ask a
question before me i was just advising
it in the chat
yeah i will ask a question please yes
yes counselor sorry counselor canola yes
thank you thank you taylor for that
counselor
thanks so far i just wanted to ask with
this new integrated system will this
their fund then stop the issues that we
sometimes get
when we've got residents who have
a traffic a manchester gp but live in
trafford
and the difficulty in accessing services
will this be the
panacea for all that is that the right
expression
i think that's definitely the right
expression um it's definitely hoped that
in terms
of simplifying some of the
organizational structures
and that will be able to work more in
partnership that registration of general
practice though will remain the same
in terms of where you're registered with
and those flows into that contractual
basis as such for general practice
um but those providers working together
what that means i think the
the absolute the objective is that a lot
of that will be made
much easier for residents etc but i
think councillor
it's you know the proof of the pudding
is in the eating and it's very much
about working on the ground and stuff
that we've already tried to do
and within our providers and working
with diane etc
that we carry on doing that really
because i think it will be the teams on
the ground
that make the biggest difference in
terms of that access
okay that's up at all counts like
another
i'm yeah it's it is about the teams on
the ground and i do have concerns
because i know it's been an issue for
a long time and it still goes on
especially if you've then got the added
of someone being in salford hospital
manchester gp and a trafford resident
and [ __ ] access
and all kinds of support it is difficult
so
yeah i'll watch this space and that's
one of the things i won't be watching
thank you thank you councillor taylor
thank you chair um i would concur with
what my colleague
and council akanova says we see it quite
frequently in
clifford particularly because it's at
the interface of a number of different
boroughs and so yeah this is a very
selling issue
um i'm just going to ask um sarah if
do you foresee any challenges with this
um
it almost sort of sort of
i've worked in the nhs a long time and
it almost sort of strikes me as like
we've gone a little bit full circle with
these types of arrangements
um as much as you know we've been very
sort of ultra local and now we're kind
of going more
um you know regional again really but um
you know one of the advantages of things
like the traffic organization or local
care organization
that it is that very sort of localized
place specific
types of services that we're really um
invested in do do you think any of that
would be
diluted or diminished in any way if we
have to sort of consider things on a
more
um regional level
um i think what we're aiming to and the
the jargon that's being used if that's
the right word jargon is sort of spatial
mapping
so we're looking at what is best done at
a greater manchester level and there are
things that if we do it together
it is better done in that way in terms
of planning
some of the delivery of specialist
services but it's going right the way
down counselor to
neighborhood levels and i think the real
sort of
prominent push is to build around our
neighborhoods
so what i think everybody's hoping is
actually it will reinforce that local
neighbour
nature of integrated community services
on the ground
um and we know that we've still got work
to do on that in terms of the local
organisation care organisation obviously
diane has been
instrumental with others about
integration but we've got more to do
with primary care networks
wider community resources assets etc
so that is across gm that has been a
key objective of the reorganization that
that becomes a prominent feature
as we go forward and it is within the
system plans that's being put into the
centre as well
for uh greater manchester so so i think
um and tom could speak on this we're
putting a lot of dashboards together as
well
about what changes and outcomes and
effect we have which is going down to
that neighborhood community
level and that's what we're going to
build it on
i think the issue is you know i'd be
it'd be
remiss of me to say it's it's hard doing
this in the middle of a pandemic
um and when we're also trying to stand
up services but i think you know
with great sorts of um gratitude to all
our colleagues really that people you
know we've got to do it and we're going
to do it i'm going to do it really
really well
or to the best that we can do for
trafford
yeah absolutely i'm sure we know how
invested you are in doing that thank you
very
uh much you for that um counselor
hartley you have a question
thank you chair yes my question was
about the
the transition i suppose so with with
you know the nhs is
is always subject to you know lots of
reorganizations and and
and the problems often seem to be in the
in the sort of transition
and so i guess thinking of thinking
about
residents and patients um
recognize the challenge of doing this in
the middle of a pandemic and
having to step up services and you know
tackle backlogs in in
particular healthcare that have arisen
because of because of the pandemic
i suppose the question is really around
what um
what sort of assurances could we get
either now or or as you know as the
plans develop maybe at future meetings
about ensuring that
continuity of care for residents
and also sort of avoiding you know
interruption and service but also
avoiding
um you know things like
sort of data being lost or data not
being handed over to
to the ics and and different
organizations
thinking about things like the
vaccination program where
we struggled in the north of the borough
i think partly because
certain general practices had closed
down and patients had moved and not
registered with new gps
a different sort of reorganization but i
guess my concern is
um you know what assurance can we give
to residents that there isn't going to
be a
you know an interruption in service
because of the reorganization
and i suppose as part of that what what
sort of
communications are we planning with
residents so that they know that this is
happening
thank you chair so um
and i could hand over to tom as well for
some of the detail in terms of the data
capture but i think in terms of what
we're hoping for councillor
is that actually residents don't see any
of these changes
because it's actually a commissioning
change in terms of that rather than
delivery on the ground
um so our hope is very much that um
residents will not be aware i mean that
is my hope that we will just carry on
and it will smoothly and transition
in terms of assurance i think you're
absolutely right about is probably
bringing back assurances in the
autumn and where we move into shadow
form and at that
point then we will be actually looking
at how um
our both in terms of our plans our
delivery our data
is actually going to the ics i
particularly don't
think we'll have this is the worst thing
i can say i'm sure
that we might remind how much of a
problem because actually we're already
within that whole ics structure in
effect as
a ccd and we haven't worked in that
i think for the um colleagues of ccgs
what we're actually saying is that the
delivery needs to carry on
over um that time coming back to give
assurances
in the um
that really um but but i don't really
see that we'll have
councillor harley would you like to
follow um sarah's response
with anything no
no no sort of follow-up question you
know i think i think that does sort of
uh yeah it does give us some reassurance
i know um
i think tom's put a comment in the chat
about the some of the data dashboards
that are being developed so
um yeah i guess a sort of boy follow up
it would be really good too
i know there's an elected member
dashboard and there's a
health inequalities dashboard you know
those were the ones that i'd flagged as
you know really interested to see those
in due course and i think if they can
if they can give us a sense uh when we
can see that data if it can give us a
sense
of um you know whether service
is continuing as normal or whether we
have seen any sort of
transitional problems uh if you like
comparing now
to what would it look like in 12 months
time when the ics is up and running
it'd be really good to try and see that
sort of data i think so
um yeah thank you chair that's hard to
save away for a lot
okay uh thank you and council answered
you had a question
oh sorry council accordingly you're
you're before council actually sorry
council accordingly sorry
uh it's it's a quick one and it's really
to
um sarah but it's equally to you karen
and um
and everybody really it's how we
how we scrutinize this as we go along i
i think we'll
have lots of questions but they'll be
the same questions from members
and i'm thinking almost of a standing
committee that
just looks at this piece uh
task and finish or whatever we do is
because it we want we want to be able to
get
quick answers out but we don't want to
overwhelm the team
we've all asking the same questions in
some ways
so i i think i think there needs to be a
communication strategy a scrutiny
strategy or what
a bit of both really and i think the
wider
council membership needs to be much more
involved because i don't think there's a
huge amount of
awareness it hasn't been a topic for
conversation
so um yeah so it's probably as well that
sarah has gone down
because it's more really to the chair
and vice chair
of the committee in some ways how we go
forward with that
council tell you do you have a view you
wanted to share
on that what about how we go forward
with scrutinizing these
these plans i think i guess we have to
have it as a sort of a regular standing
feature don't we on our um
um agenda and um
i think we need to scrutinize the the
dashboards and maybe highlight the
the the most key outcomes maybe as a
committee we need to consider what are
the most key outcomes that we as a
health scrutiny committee are
particularly interested many many
um outcomes on the dashboard but i think
you know
what do we i think i mean council
hartley highlighted about health
inequalities
um and i think maybe we keep it um
as it evolves as a regular standing item
on our
agenda that would be one of my
suggestions do you have any particular
suggestions
chair um i think it is something that we
probably are all wanting to
hear about i mean we could discuss it in
our work program
um in the towards the end of this
meeting
how other members feel generally because
obviously it's hard to get everyone's
view
um in this particular point in the
meeting so maybe it's something that we
could consider
just towards the end in that special
agenda item on our draft work plan
uh but definitely agree that it's
something that we really need to keep a
close look at and
i'm i'm really intrigued if i could just
ask at this point your community
wouldn't mind
and what the elected member dashboard
particularly is
and whether how do we access these
dashboards or they think
is it data that's presented to us i mean
how will it work and what
specifically is the elected member one
please
tom you able to answer that
yeah sorry chair i was just about to try
and come off new there and pop
very politely put my uh virtual hand up
and so we do have a raft of um
data and intelligence that's captured in
a number of dashboards but we appreciate
that
that's not perfect for everyone and
people don't necessarily engage with
with things such as tableau which is a
an online server where
lots of this data is held so we we're
working on ways in which we can
share the information through some sort
of reports written reports that we can
circulate around on a regular basis
the particular dashboard that you
referenced and goes i think on a weekly
basis or at the very
least on a bi-weekly basis to to the
exec and then i think there is a wider
elected members dashboard and that was
created when i first started working
with sarah todd
and last year actually on some of the
covered response which picks up
some of the key metrics around how we
are responding and and
later in in in the timeline how we
were responding and recovering from
colby really so that was around
service pressures that we were feeling
in the system and are we able to cope
with those
and where have we got some pinch points
that we need to collaborate around
and which is linked back into health and
social care silver that diane
uh chairs there is a raft of other
dashboards in development and some
pick up the points of the councillors
have made around uh health inequalities
and so we're currently in the process of
developing those along with neighborhood
dashboards so we can see
the differences in the neighborhoods and
the communities that we have across
trafford because we know
we're experiencing different pressures
and and people have different needs in
different areas of the borough so
those will be available they will be um
essentially
online but we can work with you too and
download those and share them
as regular as possible we are going to
be reporting into the one system board
that saru
referred to earlier on in her talk um
on a quarter basis is the current
agreement and what some of that
information is changing on a day-to-day
basis so we can report more regularly
on on certain measures and sets of data
than others
um so we we can work with you to share
that information as
readily as it's available
thank you very much tim that was really
really helpful i mean i think i could
yeah
counselor you can come in if you wish
and but just to say that i think that we
definitely would
obviously be interested in receiving
that information and perhaps when we get
to
our um plan for the rest of the year we
will kind of return
to you with our views on that yeah you
know after this meeting if that's okay
but councillor taylor i think you've
said it really but i think
when we were considering our work
streams for this year i think
health inequalities was something that
um
ourselves and and the whole um scrutiny
committee were very very
um concerned that that we really focused
on
and and so i think that that should
definitely be a key metric and a key
outcome um and i think um
the way that the dashboard was presented
to us
um over the pandemic i personally really
like the way that that data was
presented i thought it was very
accessible and sort of easy to uh to
digest you know somebody's not
necessarily a statistician and
and i think if the data could be
presented to us but some
other people may have other views but
you know in that that really sort of
accessible and visual way and that that
would be helpful but i think
as council barclays said you know we
will take it away and just consider as a
committee i don't want to make a
decision on behalf of the whole
committee
um at the end how how we go forward with
that but i think probably
neighborhood data so we can see sort of
differences and
similarities throughout the borough and
health inequalities would be our
key focus really thank you chair
thank you councillor taylor diane i
think just wanted to come in with
something
and it's just to support the the
community really the dashboard is
linked to the locality plan delivery um
and i think will be really helpful for
the committee to use to cruise
so what is all this work actually
achieving for residents which is
is absolutely what we want to answer the
point really is that the impact of
covered is significant
and so we have been set back on some of
those health inequalities because of the
pandemic and the impact that it's had
and so we as a statement
went first that sets out where we are
in relation to the impact of kobed and
then
start to see the building back and
through that dashboard going forward
chair so we can take that off and if you
declare what you would like us to bring
we can bring that back for you
thank you thank you very much then that
would be really really helpful so yes we
will get back to you of course
um any other questions just on that just
before we move to the next
question
sorry yes of course counselor
cardinality and then counselor black and
then we'll move on to
elsa acton's question thank you yeah i
suppose in some ways i
i haven't really formulated my views but
essentially what it is i want to be kept
up to date with this
and not really wait between
health scrutiny meetings so i'm
wondering whether the
ics is going to be publishing
newsletters and things like that
but it's quite a significant piece of
work that
actually we want to be kept as as
up-to-date and raise any questions so
it's really whether we use the offices
of scrutiny to
put forward those questions in between
meetings or something
like that or whether there's newsletters
going out that describe
what's happening where we are and this
sort of thing both at the greater
manchester level and at the traffic
level
okay fantastic thanks thank you for that
um
i mean again uh council calling it we
will perhaps discuss that as a committee
um in our draft work plan uh when we get
to that on the agenda
we can decide how we all want to do
things what's kind of the over
arching view of the committee and then
take that forward with officers
is that okay with you yeah fantastic
okay
and so uh councillor blackburn also
wanted to come out on this and then
councillor harding just also wanted to
speak so we'll get to eventually cancel
our accident sorry we're just finishing
off
this little bit of the discussion so
councillor blackburn please
can i ask will the i.t systems be able
to cope with the changes
and what will happen if there is
a problem
if i if i come in on that i'm not too
sure whether sarah has managed to join
um back it looks like she might have
according to the chat
um so there is a uh so
our chief digital officer paul james is
um fully involved in the greater
manchester digital and data discussions
um which is predominantly around the
issues you just raised there and
continuity of some of the its systems
but also the upgrading of upset i.t
systems across health and social care
of which money is available to invest in
some of those
um those dated it systems shall we say
um
so that is part of one of our and i
wanted to mention this earlier on but
how we manage some of the risks
throughout this process it's such
large scales change involving so many
different organizations
um that inevitably there is there is
risk within this program but what we
have a program approach as sars alluded
to in trafford
i t digital impacts are captured within
that risk
within that risk register for once of a
better phrase and that's actually
starting to be refined now as we get the
guidance out so
as we become clearer on what is um what
is going to be commissioned and
delivered
and planned at a greater manchester
level and what has devolved down into
localities into the likes of trafford
that we'll be able to plan and mitigate
against our
um any issues particularly the digital
aspects as well but there's nothing at
this moment in time
that would lead us to believe there will
be any direct impacts of the transition
on on it services
thank you for that tom um are you
satisfied with that council of blackburn
yeah okay fantastic okay okay uh
councillor harding you wanted to
mention something thanks chair it was um
to account for the accordingly
point as well and and to a couple of
other points really
this is um sarah mentioned this is a
huge piece of work it's a significant
piece of work
and it's incredibly complicated uh and
complex really
um and i chair the northwest portfolio
holders
group for northwest adafs and
it's um a piece of work that we've had
our eye on from a social care point of
view
and we're due to have a session in july
and one of the things that i
said was and we've done a lot of work
with the lga
and i sit on the lga community
well-being board too
we have some concerns around things like
the citizens boys children and young
people in public health and social care
and i think as as mike is saying really
i think when scrutiny is done well it's
absolutely brilliant and i think this
piece of work needs to be probably a
regular scrutiny
item but as a former chair we know how
um the agenda can get really busy at
health scrutiny
and this probably there's a lot of
detail in this so i guess my offer is
and we're holding a meeting at northwest
adas
and i've said that what i want the
session to be
is easy to understand with the language
that everybody understands and even if
we need to draw pictures i don't care
but we've got to do it in a way that
members understand because i
know help inside and out but there are
things that i don't know about this and
i'm not afraid to ask a question and say
i have no idea what you mean
by that so i don't want any counsellors
on screens
to be understand what it means because i
think we're all learning as we go along
so i've spoken to the chair this evening
and said all
um health scrutiny chairs and vice
chairs are going to be invited to this
session in july
if the vice chair and the chair can't
attend the northwest adas
if one of the councillors from scrutiny
wants to come along to that meeting
and i'll definitely share the slide deck
with um scrutiny members
well the point of the session is to make
it so that
the ics becomes something that's
able that people are able to understand
so they know how to formulate questions
they know the process
and obviously i have trust and faith in
sorry diane and tom and
emma offices that are leading on this
but as counsellors i'm sure that you'll
want to be
across the detail of this so if that
session is something that you think
would be of interest and to keep you up
for today then i'll i'll make sure that
you'll sent that invitation
thank you council honey that is really
really helpful and i'm sure would be
hugely valuable
uh to members uh we have a question from
uh councillor taylor
when is that meeting do you know when it
is at the moment i have a feeling
it's um ends july it's either the 22nd
or 25th let me double check and i'll
send it to fabiola i'll send the dates
and the invites to fabiola it'll come
from norfolk
but it's going out to all the chairs and
vice chairs across the northwest of
scrutiny
because we've said as a northwest adas
we think scrutiny should be involved in
this
and be up to speed with it so as soon as
i've got that invite i'll send it to
fabiola and then she can share it
amongst the
community that's fantastic thank you so
much counselor that would be
really helpful and uh councillor taylor
said in the chat and i totally supported
that
we really do need it to be in lay terms
that we can really all understand
the changes because obviously we can't
scrutinize effectively if we don't
really understand
the language so really do appreciate
that you know that aspect of it
is picked up but again and perhaps we
can get back to you with
names of people who would like to attend
would that be useful
fantastic so thank you so so much so has
anyone got any further questions just on
this particular topic that we were
discussing before i bring counselor
actor in accent into asking the question
no okay so council acton please yeah it
was just really
a follow-up from council sophie
[Music]
yes he was a follow-on from
uh councillor uh sophie taylor's
first question really or point that she
made and that was
a very simple one the integration of
healthcare
is something that has been talked about
and uh trialed uh before
um on many occasions in my experience
and it
it feels like sometimes these things
go round and come round again and
and unfortunately they they seem to have
failed um or we wouldn't be
trying to do it again and
and i i just wonder really that
you know will this one
be successful and why would you think
that it would be successful i do think
also that the question that
might pose really about how do we
monitor
it is complex and it is complicated
and the different areas of
healthcare staff
sort of um will go into their
own little silo when times get tough uh
because that's where they're actually
based and
where where they are paid to do a
job and and that's the
complexity of it really um but we do
have to keep
things very simple i hope that we we do
succeed because i think it's really
important
you know for the people of
trafford and the people of greater
manchester that it does succeed um
but but i think to succeed
you do have to monitor uh
in a simple fashion the performance
and and the impact it has on
on the people of greater manchester
so i suppose
i'm asking why do we think this will be
successful
when others fail
so are you able to respond now
i'm i'm able to be heard whether i'm
able to respond to counsellor acton's
question
i'm not sure um so i suppose
from my point of view it feels like it's
an evolution
rather than a sort of step back
in terms of what we're doing um in that
it's the next
step that we need to go to in terms of
simplifying what we do to be quite
honest
um and also that we actually have
leadership across our providers sat in
our localities
which we haven't actually had if we were
honest in terms of sitting down with um
council leadership etc
so so to me it's an evolution it's not
maybe a stop and start again
um in terms of doing that i think in
terms of how
whether we know it's successful i think
it needs to be outcome-based i know it's
something that this
scrutiny has said for a long time in
terms of outcomes
actually looking at the inequalities
taking us down to ward level if not
community level
and all of those things we've tried to
build into the
local care alliance and the provider
collaborative in terms of that whole
monitoring of our integration process
so i suppose in terms of is it going to
work
i really hope it is are we going to be
clearer in terms of our
outcomes we're really trying to do that
um in terms of doing it and i think
it will be simpler and i think if it is
simpler for the whole of the sort of
integrated health and social care system
that has got to be a plus to be quite
honest um and that's
someone who has led the complicated
system that's being made simpler so um
but i think you know in terms of doing
that the the biggest worry for me
if and i'm sorry i dropped out i've had
real problems um
with my work laptop on zoom actually so
in terms of
um for me the biggest sort of warrior
risk is actually
losing our workforce over this time
and really maintaining and that might
have been said when i dropped out but
really maintaining the continuity of
what we've done
and so that actually isn't a stop start
and it is an evolution
and we are carrying on building what
we've done really um
but i think we need to be far more
outcome focused and that's what tom's
been working with with other colleagues
across the council and the nhs in terms
of really targeting
our focus for the future thank you thank
you sir
would you like to add anything david no
okay fantastic so uh counselor heart it
has a question please
thank you chair just just thinking about
um what sarah saying in our last answer
have have
ics has been trialled anywhere already
i seem to remember hearing about some
some regions moving forward
sooner than others so i just wonder if
there any lessons learning from that as
to
what we might expect i mean i'm fully
behind the idea of more collaboration
less competition but i just wanted to
learning from elsewhere in the country
that we are
that we are looking at
um i think you know if you had some
people in greater manchester that say
we're the forerunners of it but
um i think actually there is a lot of
learning that we can have from other
parts of the country
one of the issues is that the ics's are
of different size really
um so there's some that are very small
probably the size of you know just a bit
bigger than trafford really in terms of
population and then there's
ones you know the size of greater
manchester and bigger so
but i think the king's fund has done
quite a lot of work on those principles
of integration for an ics
what you need to build upon to make it
successful um and that's the sort of um
the foundation that a lot of people are
taking forward
i think for us actually you know the
north west will have three ics's
um and i think um i know what councillor
taylor was saying um
earlier about when you look at
integration on the ground and making
sure that actually it's responsive to
people across boundaries
i think we need to be responsive across
our northwest boundaries and that
learning as well
so there is learning to be done from
langston cumbria in terms of some of the
things they've done
merseyside um as well etcetera um but i
think the core will come from that real
king's fund principles
of what we've done the issue is they are
different sizes to be quite honest
councillor hartley so it's the
principles rather maybe than the ways of
working
thank you thank you sarah and nobody
else has really indicated any other
questions but i just have one
question which i would really appreciate
and an answer to if that's okay
and ellen are very kindly put in the
chat that um
that you are going to be working to
ensure that you reduce inequality and
that's going to be
a key part of the delivery plans and i
just wondered if anyone could provide us
with a
kind of real-life example of how you
think
these the integrated care system can
actually achieve that
thank you
i'm happy to start the answer on that if
that would be helpful thank you thank
you
i'll be very very helpful thank you and
i think we're where we've got we'll get
some real value through these integrated
care plans will be
um our ability to have the conversations
on that place-based locality
neighborhood level
um so what and make sure that we're
actually making
the referrals and the signposting
between the different parts of the
system
so a lot of our inequalities in traffic
are driven not between deficits in
health or social care but actually from
obviously we
talk about this all the time don't we
some of the wider determinants of health
so whether it's about education
employment the environmental aspects and
i think one of the strengths of this way
of working
will be that we'll be able to be
developing a through the locality plan
a plan right down to that neighborhood
level where we can start seeing which
are the things that
are needing to be done more
systematically
through the health service or through
other services but not necessarily with
a response being
all part of the nhs so an example might
be
on say the work we're doing on
immunization at the moment
whereabouts by taking a really we know
that we've got an
inequality gap in the uptake of
immunisation we see this every time when
we're seeing this with covid
but by taking a collective approach and
collective responsibility to the
delivery of the vaccination program
we've been working with voluntary and
community sector to
identify community leaders who can
promote vaccination with us
we're making sure that all of our staff
whether health or social care
really understand the importance of
vaccination and can promote it
in the work that they do but also we're
doing the community engagement work so
going out and listening to our local
population
about the reasons that they have for
being hesitant about vaccination or for
not wanting vaccination
so by listening to people and having
engaging in that dialogue
we're able to both target our messages
more effectively
but also use better messengers because
more appropriate to the populations that
we're trying to target
so by sharing the sharing the targets
that we have around particularly
inequalities
and where we know those gaps are we're
able to take a much more focused
approach to making sure that we level up
and bring up the um the system so that
we get
the appropriate care and the appropriate
response to people
but as i say that may not all be about
um that may not all be about a health
service response
another but a lot of it may be driven by
data that's held by the health service
so for example that uh immunization gap
that i just mentioned or similarly with
obesity where we know again that there's
a deprivation link
to obesity having um our nhs systems and
our gp systems well set up
to pick up the people who we know are
overweight or obese and then to offer
interventions which may not be medical
interventions
to that group of people means that we're
much more likely to get people engaging
with our services
so that that's the approach that we're
hoping to be able to take and that we
see
that we see this integrated system being
more likely to
um make smoother because of that shared
sharing of those targets um i don't know
if anyone else wants to comment on
on what i've said um
i'll come back in just for 30 seconds
and obviously agree with everything
ellen has said
um i think the other thing for for me
about what will be different
in the new system is um that advocacy
for inequalities as well
so general practice even though we have
tried to involve general practice
they will be involved much more at the
heart of decision making
and as a collective so general practice
in the north with sitting with the south
with the west etcetera and actually that
really brings inequalities at the center
of all the debate
and also with debate with maybe other
organizations where
that inequalities is obviously really
part of their agenda
but maybe not as in the forefront of the
agenda for on a neighborhood
level um in terms of that so even today
we were having discussions about
inequality next to equity what does that
mean if we're moving resources etc
and having examples on the table all the
time around that because we now have
representatives of the primary care
network sat at the one system board
sat at the provider collaborative
working across
those sort of five networks and that
will be an absolute foundation as we go
forward
which i think again is different from
what we've had before it's an evolution
of the integrated system
um and brings inequalities i think much
more firmly to the table with every
discussion
thank you thank you sarah thank you
eleanor that was really really helpful
it's so good to have some actual
examples of understanding so we can
appreciate what these changes
mean and how we're going to have an
impact and just a final call then um as
we finish
um this agenda item any final very quick
questions for our officers
no okay i don't see anybody asking and i
think everyone has been covered yes
so and just like to thank officers um
very very much for your time and for
presenting and
to us and answering our questions and
just really to summarize
the recommendations so that we know what
we we would like and what we all agree
to
so the recommend recommendations were
that the report is noted
and commented on when i think we have
done that haven't we and then the second
one's at the
traffic equality plan we refresh to be
made available to the committee
well i think we probably have extended
our requirements there haven't we and
we've said that
we would probably like much more
information on certain access to those
dashboards on
health inequalities and neighborhood
data but and we'll determine perhaps how
we
receive and obtain that data in our work
plan
later on this evening so if we can get
back to you on that but obviously we do
definitely
want to hear far more about and keep
very very close to this
and and just as a final thing um in
terms of obviously returning to i think
we'll be returning to it very frequently
we will update you
exactly how often there's a final thing
could i perhaps ask in terms of
sharing this with um our wider member
population
is that a document or um a kind of
briefing note that could be
kind that's in lay terms that we could
send out to all members because i think
it is such a major
uh change to the way that health
services are delivered
or commissioned i suppose and that i
think all our members need to know and
if there was a document that we could
perhaps send round to all members that
would be really useful
so we could absolutely do that
councillor barclay we've also been
providing bite
size um sort of presentations for the
staff which is very simple about what
can happen so we can look at that as
well if you want so we could
talk to fabiola about what's the best
way to do that so we can absolutely do
that
fantastic i mean the committee would
appreciate that if you think that would
be a good idea for our colleagues then
um that would be really really helpful
so so thank you so so much i really
appreciate all your
um work this evening and um helping to
inform us
um on the massive changes ahead thank
you so so much thank you
okay so moving on to our next agenda
item which is again
another really massive piece of work for
the council and its partners
and it's the traffic council poverty
strategy for 21 22
and i'm not sure who is speaking on this
but again
really really welcome the report thank
you uh for presenting it to us in
written form
and um i'm not sure who's presenting to
us but if we could have
just a really quick overview and then of
course just um again as always
a health scrutiny committee really
concerned about its impact on
health inequalities if you could just um
as a kind of beginnings
to our discussion um inform us how this
is going to
help tackle the inequalities and
particularly we read in the report about
the
extreme inequalities as opposed to north
versus south and that would be really
helpful thank you great thanks so it's
me councillor barclay and we've also got
um diane geary um oh thank you with us
as well so diana will uh
will fill in and any gaps i know no
doubt leave
um so yeah just say i mean you've had
the report and thanks for
for sending the questions and
through that that's really helpful i
mean it's it's just it's really good to
to come speak to health scrutiny tonight
um
about the the poverty strategy work and
also really great to have had those
those questions because they're really
really important ones and
obviously really keen to have health
scrutiny is interesting
in this work um given the high
correlation between low household income
and
poor health outcomes which we're all
aware of and that have been no more
evidenced
and than during the last 16 16 months or
or so and it's clearly
vital that we tackle poverty and traffic
if we're to address
some of those health inequalities and
poor health
outcomes and before i just talk to any
detail in the report like i said
i won't say go through it all because
you've had it in advance and i just just
think it's worth stating what we all
know that although trafford is perceived
as a relatively affluent bullet borough
relative certainly to some of the other
boroughs in greater manchester
more than one in five children in the
borough are living in households with
incomes below the
poverty line and we have some areas
that are very much home to high
concentrations of
decoration and and poverty and that of
course bites the lives of
the people that it affects but also
damages all of us
and as high levels of poverty result and
additional pressures on
local services and acts as a drag on on
the local economy as well as the
national
um economy so the report provided uh to
members response to a number of specific
questions that the
the committee sent through um
i'll assume you've all had chance to
read the the report but i just wanted to
start by
making sure everyone had a good
understanding as to the background of
the strategy and the approach that we've
taken
and are taking in the future because i
do think it's a lot of work's gone into
kind of getting us to this this point
and i think it's
important that all elective members um
have a good understanding of kind of the
journey so far but also where we're
trying to get to
in the future so development the
strategy began before the
the pandemic um and then
that that work was done in partnership
with um traffic housing trust and other
partners through the trafford
partnership
board but was put on hold in march last
year so
we intentionally kind of put that work
on hold um as
officers and others responded to the the
pandemic
but then picked that work back up in
september october time which meant we
were able to publish
um the the one year strategy that we're
currently working to
at the beginning of this year so we're
able to move quite quickly from sort of
the autumn
onwards which was a which was a good
thing
but that said we're reflecting on the
the pandemic a decision was taken that
we would just have a one year strategy
for now
and partly in kind of recognition of
some of the
the issues that the the pandemics
created but also because
also in recognition that kind of what
the long-term consequences of
of the pandemic on the economy and
therefore on poverty
and are currently kind of uncertain so
we've got this one year strategy in
place but we'll be working with partners
over the next
12 months to develop a three-year
strategy so a longer term strategy which
will take us from 2022
through to 2025 and that will very much
be a partnership
strategy in terms of just implementing
the
the one-year strategy a poverty action
group has been set up
that's made up of and i'm i'm on there
of course but also council officers from
relevant departments
trafficked housing trust and a number of
uh voluntary community faith
and social enterprise sector
organizations so we've got really good
membership on there so
although this is a one-year council
poverty strategy
we're in a really good place in terms of
developing the the partnership approach
to this work over the longer
the longer term and we've got an action
tracker which tracks progress against a
number of
of areas and details in the strategy
and i think just worth pointing that out
because obviously poverty is such a
a broad huge kind of cross-cutting issue
in the um in the strategy we've got nine
different
areas that we've identified that we want
to focus on
and so clearly a lot of work to do so
the action tracker enables us to
to do two things one identify um
actions where there's already activity
under
underway in the borough to respond to a
specific issue
and and secondly to identify actions
where
where there are gaps and where we feel
that there's there's a need for more
action in trafford and where those um
gaps are identified that's where the the
poverty action group
looks to take the lead um in responding
to those to those things
so we're not saying everything um every
bit of activity or action in relation to
the poverty strategy
uh needs to be taken forward by the
poverty action group we're saying
there's already some really good stuff
in the borough happening we're
acknowledging
that making sure we're tracking progress
against those things whilst also then
identifying gaps
and and taking action uh where
appropriate against
against those just to
i think you'd ask one of the questions
um
was you'd asked around um kind of
tangible differences to
to residents in the borough of the of
the of the one year strategy
and because there's a lot in there i
just thought i wanted to sort of pick
out a
couple of examples that just illustrate
that kind of way of working so
so as per the arrangements for
delivering the strategy um
a number of actions are being taken
forward through other forums so for
example the live well in my community
strategic design group
has taken forward work to promote credit
union membership in the borough
and as their members will know credit
unions support people to access
affordable credit
and can play a major role in helping
people to avoid the poverty premium
and avoid problem debt and a bit of an
issue in trafford in in terms of the
credit union presence is
has historically been lower than in in
some other areas
and so we've seen the opening of a new
manchester credit union branch in
stratford more recently
and sale credit union also relatively
recently
and has started to provide on-site
services to residents in
in partisan through the hub there so
we'll be tracking credit union
membership levels through the strategy
and credit union membership will make a
material that provides a
material difference to financial
well-being in the borough so that's an
example where
there was already some good work
underway through another forum
and we're tracking the the impact that
has through the poverty strategy
but not necessarily taking leadership on
it
and then in contrast to that the poverty
action group has identified a gap in
respect of employers
offering advanced salary payments to
employees in the borough
advance salary payments can stop people
having access
and sorry can stop people having to
access short-term high-interest loans
for relatively small amounts of money
when they're short before the end of the
month
for example accessing high interest debt
to cover the cost of replacing the
broken washing machine or cooker
this is an area where the poverty action
group has identified
the need for further work and we'll work
with employers as well as looking at the
council's own practices
to promote advanced salary payments so
that we can support people to avoid
problem debt
so again this will make a material
difference to the financial well-being
of residents
and both those examples kind of fall
under the debt and poverty premium
themes identified in the in the strategy
just to say i just wanted to pick out a
couple of other things that
from the report that i just think it's
worth highlighting um
at the moment just in respect to
question three and
would just like to reiterate as stated
in the report that the
one-year poverty strategy was used was
developed using data from the joint
strategic needs assessment
and is designed to complement existing
strategies such as the health and
well-being strategy
and as obviously poverty will have a
positive impact on on the health and
addressing poverty will have a
um positive impact on the health and
well-being of
residents and similarly linked to that
in terms of
um question four that you put um put
forward
so that was how how the poverty strategy
will build on the recovery
strategy and corporate priorities to
tackle inequalities in the borough
and clearly the the sort of details set
out in the report
shows how the poverty strategy links
into those things where relevant and
where appropriate
and how it's aligned with the the
council's corporate
corporate plan so really pleased
actually with the work that we've done
through the poverty strategy that we've
not done
and and this is i think something that
has happened in other local authority
areas in the past sometimes work around
addressing poverty has been done sort of
in isolation
or kind of too separate from um
other work that's going on uh within
that local authority area and that's
kind of the
the opposite to the approach that we've
taken um
here in trafford as i think members can
probably can probably see from
from the the detail that they've got in
the report and from some of the stuff
that i've just been
been speaking about in terms of just
measuring success so the action plan
tracker for the poverty strategy
features baseline data
against which progress um on actions
will be measured and that's really
important the council's
business intelligence unit to support
him with that work and i do think that's
vital because
we've got to be able to see not just in
terms of this one year strategy
but i think in terms of the the longer
term strategy i really want us to be
able to say things like
you know we've increased the number of
um families that are taking up healthy
start vouchers or a number of families
that are claiming free school meal
support where they're eligible
or number of people who've got credit
union accounts and are there for
accessing affordable
and affordable loans it's really
important we can kind of put some
numbers around some of that
that stuff so i think that's absolutely
crucial so i'm glad you asked that
question
um and then the last thing to to finish
off
on was um you asked about how health
scrutiny can
contribute to this piece of work and
have value to it i think this is a
really good
um start uh tonight did want to sort of
um ask that if if the committee wants to
that the committee sends a
a representative to join the poverty
action group so that would mean someone
a name person from the committee coming
along to those
meetings that we have every couple of
months so that meeting made up of
officers and partners and myself etc
that would be a really good link for us
i mean happy to kind of bring this work
back to
to committee again in the future but i
just think having that
ongoing link um
through a committee member being part of
the poverty action group would be
particularly
particularly helpful so hope that's uh
in terms of the report and then my kind
of
whiz through that there that's kind of
good good background good overview for
you
and myself and diana happy to to take
any questions
thank you very much graeme that was
incredibly helpful really really useful
a very exciting opportunity for a member
of health scrutiny
uh to join the poverty action group
which perhaps we can come to at a later
point in the discussion
and first of all any questions i know
councillor chilton has asked um if you
could
erase a question and then counselor
taylor but and please do
put in the chat if you'd like to ask a
question uh councillor
chilton first please thank you very much
chair
um two points if i may chair
um the first is um i
don't i know that the report does resist
this temptation which has been going on
for far too long
of them being them saying the po
all the the poor areas of trafford in
the north
um and as as though there aren't any in
the south
um this i've found for 10 years very
tiresome
because there is significant pockets of
deprivation in the south of the borough
um no of course it's skewed by the fact
that of course there are
extremes of wealth in the south of the
borough
which skew this completely statistically
and of course there are more wealthy
areas in the south of the borough
so those pockets of deprivation in the
south have often historically found it
difficult
to secure funding um to secure other
areas of support simply because some i
mean thankfully most funders and things
now do
do super output areas rather than
looking at things in the rounding wards
but historically that's been a major
problem and i'm not
i'm pleased the council seems to be
getting out this mindset
because it's patronizing to the north
and b it ignores
the areas of deprivation in the south so
i'm pleased that that
we're getting over this now um at the
other point i have is and
mem other members will roll their eyes
because it's all i ever seem to talk
about
but there is the major issue and and
references made to it in the report in
my view
that contributes to poverty is how
um major housing
you know we have landlords i mean
trafford housing trusts are obviously on
board with this report and other members
may take issue with this but to my mind
they aren't the problem
what are the problem are private
landlords um who
profit from people being in very
substandard conditions
but also i'm sad to say and other
members will hear me witter on about
this time after time
there are social landlords uh one or two
of them that frankly
provide a shocking service to their
residents we
shout about new developments in
partnership with certain certain social
landlords as though this is
and i'm going to nick councillor
aquinola's word here the the panacea
to all these problems that are that are
happening
new social land housing is very very
welcome and badly needed in trafford
but we forget that there are people
living in existing social housing for
whom the problem is not going to get
better
um simply because the investment is
never seems to be there um
and of course in trafford we have a
specific issue it doesn't exist
necessarily as much in other boroughs
but when we say to people who are in
overcrowded or substandard housing
oh there's you might need to go and find
some private accommodation private
rented accommodation
that might be an option in manchester it
might be an option stock but
trafford is a lot more difficult because
the cost of private land private renting
is
as astronomical sometimes as it is to
buy somewhere that to me is something
that
really needs rooting out in this poverty
strategy
housing is a major contributor to it and
i would very much like to see that
focused on thank you very much chair
thank you council chilton um council
whitson would you like to respond to
councillor chilton please yeah
as a science counselor children so yeah
i mean two things there to respond to i
mean i just
i mean i think you're absolutely right
obviously there's there's sort of
pockets of deprivation and high levels
of poverty
um across the borough and
some of those concentrations are greater
more significant in terms of the number
of people in in some parts of the
borough compared to
to others and there's also i mean just
further than that there is also kind of
the issue of kind of what
what's the what was it like for someone
who's in a low income family but living
in a more affluent area and what does
that mean because that experience
can be quite difficult different
significantly different
and to the experience of people living
in sort of low-income households in
areas that are
more generally kind of deprived and so
yes
i think there's there's something to for
us to think about there but but equally
as you said we're not necessarily um
just saying that this poverty strategy
is is focused on
certain parts of the of the borough
do you think we can do some quite
exciting stuff in in the north of the
borough
around sort of addressing problem debt
increasing access to affordable credit
that we can learn from in other parts of
of trafford so i just think that that
part of the borough is particularly um
right for some some exciting kind of
initiatives on
in in terms of that specifically in
terms of the i mean obviously housing
and homelessness is one part of the
um the focus of the the poverty strategy
as you've seen
i think that um some of the issues that
are flagged
go beyond the the scope of the the
strategy or the remit of the poverty
action group
not saying they're not important issues
to respond to because because they
really are
so i think that's a really good prompt
for us as the
poverty action group for diane and i to
go away
and just have a look at our action
tracker and some of the things we've
identified on the housing and
homelessness
um priority area and just make sure
we've kind of got everything covered off
and you know we have got a lot covered
off in there but we
we perhaps want to go away and just have
a have a look at that and just make sure
we
we do that so i think it's a good good
problem that councillor chelsea
i mean i think i would say as well in
terms of the role of role of housing
providers
i mean people living um in your housing
or traffic housing trust properties or
whoever their social landlord might be
obviously that comes with with that
almost always comes with access to to
good quality services for example
good quality benefits advice services
welfare rights services
support that's not available to to
people living in privately rented
accommodation and the kind of recurring
sort of
challenge i guess or question that's
asked by um
by those interested in tackling poverty
at a local level is how do you access
those people living in privately rented
accommodation because they are often
hidden away from services
to a greater extent than people living
in in socially rented accommodation so
again i think that's something for us to
be mindful of of not just through the
poverty strategy work but
as a borough as a as a whole across the
board
would you like to come back in council
chilton
yes so just uh on that i mean i have no
doubt that trafford housing trusts
provide good quality service to their
residents i make no comment on anybody
else
um but um on that i'm aware that some of
it's out of scope counseling with him
i think i would just like some feedback
in the future
as to how you've drilled down into this
and what outcomes
have come from it so thank you very much
chair it's very useful
okay thank you councillor taylor
thank you so much and we really really
welcome this and absolutely
want to support this work in in health
scrutiny can i just ask a couple of
specific questions
i've read the report obviously uh and
forgive me if i've
missed it or i've misunderstood it or
not read properly
where can the um again the
the outcomes of the tracker be accessed
where can we
monitor those um that data and those
um those outcomes uh graham so that's
one question
and another question was um has the
strategy or will the strategy be
um disseminated or shared more widely
with the public
in trafford because some of the um
outcomes of the strategy maybe rely on
or would be enhanced by public sort of
involvement really people knowing where
to
access maybe you know it talks about
um one of the examples was maximizing
household benefit and one of those might
be you know by
um benefit maximum household income i
should say one of those might be through
benefit maximization and
sometimes people aren't always aware of
how they can optimize their household
benefit or
some some of the outcomes real would be
enhanced by
engagement from the public and if if the
public don't
aren't aware that this is a strategy you
know aim
available to anybody really that they
may not
sort of know how to to um
you know to take advantage of that
really and then there's just one of the
outcomes of the nine that i noticed it's
called go with the flow
um are you able to expand on that what
does that i mean all the others are
fairly
self-explanatory but i didn't know what
go with the flow men and forgive me if
i've not read enough retail to
understand that myself so there's three
three things there that i was
particularly interested in so yes on
that last question sophie so that that's
in relation to
um access to to sanitary products for
you
so the period probably work but they're
in poverty
trying to move away from sort of talking
about food poverty and
imperial poverty and sort of atomizing
poverty in that in that way so we've
used a different
different term there so i'll in terms of
the the second bit of your
your question uh sophie i mean
um yeah so i mean obviously the one-year
strategy is publicly
available and we're taking a partnership
approach to developing the longer term
three-year strategy
but then in addition to that you'll know
you'll have noticed in the report i
think it's in the report we mentioned
the poverty truth commission work
yeah yeah so that's a really exciting um
bit of work that we're taking forward in
the the borough so poverty truth
commissions they have run in other
places not a huge number of places but
it's a
an approach whereby you bring people
with lived experience of poverty
together with decision makers in the
same room they meet every
ev every month for at least a year
sometimes they end up meeting for for
longer than that
so you might have the leader of a you
might the
chief executive of large local
businesses business in there you might
have the
leader of a local council you might so
you'll have 15 sort of
um civic and business leaders as part of
the poverty youth commission and 15
people with lived experience of poverty
and they they form the commission
and they meet every month for like i say
at least 12 months
and the idea of that is to identify
issues facing those people who are
experiencing poverty and because you've
got the people with sort of power and
kind of clout in the room
responses to those issues so where those
projects have been run well in other
places
they've been really impactful so salford
had one probably two or three years ago
now
and it led to some changes in terms of
things that the council did but also
that businesses in salford and other
organizations did
and so it's a really exciting bit of
work we're we're
setting up the policy truth commission
now uh we've got stretford public health
hall
involved in in that and hopefully in
terms of running it because it's not
really meant to be a council run thing
if you see what to me
so they're working with us to take it
forward
that'll start running from the autumn
time and then the
outputs from the poverty truth
commission will directly inform the
longer term strategy um so i think
that's a that's a really good that's not
always happening
where places have had poverty strategies
in other localities around the country
they've not necessarily aligned the sort
of poverty strategy work with the
poverty truth commission work but we're
very much doing that in trafford which i
think is a really good way of doing it
and so i'm really pleased that we've
been able to to take that forward and
then on the first
bit of your question i'll ask diane if
she wants to if she can come in
on the kind of reporting of outcomes um
yes uh councilloritum in terms of the um
poverty action
and tracker each of the nine themes that
have been described each have a separate
tab and we have representation from
across
the council um and partners that share
with us
um the the actions that we've got in
there in the benchmark
and the um deliverables so the actual
tracker we discuss
on a monthly basis so um each month we
take a couple of those themes and go
into a lot more detail
and work out what the next set of
actions and follow-ups is required
and we then share that action tracker in
its entirety
with the actual steering group which is
um chaired by
councillor whittem and that's where the
terms of reference are included in the
back of this report
and has the membership so the membership
has
trafford housing trust bread and butter
and the trafford collective
um representatives from the cab and so
it's a
very wide um widespread coverage of
individuals and organizations
on that group and it's there that we
take that tracker for them to have a
look
and uh and delve into it and pose any
questions
so if there is a representative from the
health scrutiny committee
you would have access to all of that
tracker and then can um you know query
and check that back with us
at any point in time so it is it's open
for anybody on that
uh steering group to to ask and uh
um and as as counselor rob chilton's
mentioned about the homelessness we'll
take that back now and delve in so i've
had a quick look on the tracker while
he was speaking and so i can see where
it's linked to the various different
strategies
but i'll go back and delve into that in
a little bit more detail around the
landlords etc
but that is that opportunity and that's
what we would definitely welcome
thank you very much both of you for your
answers thank you
yes thank you and and just before i move
to um
uh council hartley uh councillor akanela
has asked
and how are you accessing the lived
experienced people
as living in poverty after a divorce is
very
or whilst the student is very different
from generational poverty
thank you so so when i think
in other areas where commissions have
already taken place or people have been
accessed through service providers and
through
volunteering community groups so so i
imagine we'll take the
the same approach in in traffic i don't
want to kind of pre-judge
exactly how that'll be done i mean it's
worth saying that the
um the the commissioners the grassroots
commissioners people looked at
experience
of poverty won't necessarily be sort of
fully representative of
of the population as a whole because
it's quite hard to sort of make
15 people representative of a population
as a whole and
you know we have to acknowledge that
people's experiences are different did
just make me think having seen their
council like another question though i'm
just reflecting on on the second bit of
sophie's question
in terms of developing the the longer
term strategy we've got the poverty
truth commission work
we've got the the partnership approach
so the strategy will be developed the
long-term strategy
will be developed in partnership and
will be a partnership strategy
and we need to think about how we come
back to elective members to help inform
the development of that sort of later
this year early next
year and we might well i'm and we will
keep an open mind
in terms of of wider involvement and
engagement to kind of get that input
um from both kind of residents and and
organizations across the
the borough so i think it's a really
interesting area quite excited about
what we can do in terms of some of that
engagement work
just need to keep a kind of an open mind
as to
um as to how we go about doing that and
who we engage i think it's really
important that we do that
could i perhaps follow that up agreement
with something that picks up on what
council chilton was saying that and
perhaps it would be good if we had
a um we did have a represent
representatives
living references from the south of the
borough as well so that there's a
geographical spread
around the borough i don't know if how
are you going to do your sampling to get
i mean it's not going to be a
representative sample but to make sure
that the south is represented as well so
that we do reflect
what council chilton was was informing
of us as well yeah
well that's absolutely yeah we'll feed
feed down make sure that's covered off
okay fantastic
okay so uh council hartley had a
question
it was well actually cancer i can earl's
uh
question that she put into the chat as
as um
sort of covered my point really it's a
really good example that she gives about
you know to a different um you know
there are relative levels of poverty and
uh
you know poverty in in some parts of the
borough is is more
long-standing more endemic than others
um i mean i agree with what cancer
children said that there are you know
pockets of poverty in all in all parts
of the bureau but
i thought my comment was really i think
i think like
like so many things kobe has sort of
brought this into sharp relief and
there's you know there's never been
a more urgent time to to look at the
poverty strategy and take take the work
forward because
what what covert has shown certainly
from residents that i've spoken to
local businesses is that you know there
are an awful lot of people
who who are now in poverty and have
recently been put into poverty people in
precarious insecure positions
um you know it's the adage that a lot of
people are only one
paycheck away from from you know being
in poverty and being in trouble and
experience has really
proved that and i think um uh what
council taylor said about um you know
ensuring people have access to advice
and
and the like i think is is key because
certainly there's been a lot of people
who've
suddenly found themselves in in real
difficulty in in
you know debt with food insecurity
problems
uh fuel insecurity problems and if
you know they're simply not either not
known where to turn to
or in some cases you know frankly
probably been embarrassed to seek the
advice that you know
perhaps other residents wouldn't be so
so there really is something in that and
i and i think
you know that's the sort of changing
nature in a way of
of poverty in the borough so um yeah i
mean i was encouraged by what councilor
whitson just just said to be honest but
i think you know poverty is
is the main driver of health
inequalities um you know i agree with
what councillor chilton said that there
are
concerns about the standards of housing
and and there's probably and there are
probably limitations on what we can do
about that
locally um but poverty is the main
driver and it's
you know that's that's the thing we have
to tackle so yeah really support the
work and
really encouraged to hear from uh from
councillor with him and
from offices about the work they're
doing thank you
thank you council hartley are there any
final questions for our officers
no and in that case and i that we've
been asked if we would like to send a
representative to the poverty action
group that's a
fantastic invitation and great
opportunity for
health scrutiny committee would would a
member like to volunteer
can i volunteer ben hartley
if council hartley would you be
interested
in that nomination there all right well
yeah i i i yeah i would be interested
and i'm yeah grateful for
counselor acton and and and taylor
support but yeah well i would definitely
be interested in in
being part of that work on the poverty
action group i think it is important for
somebody from the committee to be
involved and uh uh
yeah obviously bearing in mind what what
what diane said to us i uh
you know as a member of the committee
i'd you know undertake to come back and
and report on the work that they
that the action group has been doing so
i think i think it's really good to have
that link
yeah well thank you council hartley so
hopefully
um the rest of committee are happy with
council hartley being our representative
anybody not i'm not happy to say
no everyone's really happy with that
thank you very stopping late with that
that's fantastic
so we don't have any further questions
but just to say thank you very very much
for bringing the piece of work to us
this evening
as everyone has said it's hugely
important it's an absolutely um
vital piece of work that you're
undertaking and really is so crucial
and trying to limit those inequalities
that we we know exists
so much so just to kind of summarize uh
from the recommendations
um the report was for noting well
obviously we have noted it and
we thank you for it uh we would perhaps
just ask you if you could come back
uh with updates via council hartley but
specifically
uh you said you're going to perhaps look
at poverty in the south making sure that
you reflected that
within the strategy and that you also
looked um at your
housing and homelessness hodan's
homelessness dashboard just to check
and that that's um being followed as
closely as committee would like
and um of course just to say that
council hartley will be our
representative
and hopefully he'll be able to come back
to us and you did say that he would be
able to
access the action plan tracker so
perhaps
that could be shared with the committee
via council of hartley
is that does that seem reasonable to the
officers
yeah and the committee yes okay so thank
you so so much really appreciate your
time this evening and we look forward to
hearing back from you obviously there
won't be a set time because i think we
will just
keep hearing back from council hartley
on a regular basis but
could i just check how often does the
poverty action group meet
it's every couple of months okay so we
can expect
every uh committee meeting we can have
um some feedback from
council hartley that's fantastic okay
thank you so so much really appreciate
your time thank you
okay so moving on to um our next agenda
item
uh which is our draft work plan uh going
forward
um members have had the opportunity to
look at um
what has been scheduled what what we
have asked to come back for
future uh periods of time and
is there anything that members would
like us to actually
put into our work program we're not
going to decide on it tonight obviously
it would take a lot of time
we need to kind of think of how we
balance things out obviously we want to
integrate
every everyone's wishes into our action
plan as far
as we possibly can so if members do have
any area of work they would
like us to put on our agenda this is the
time to share it with us
yes councillor blackburn
thank you um i have concerns
about um the lack of opportunity
for residents to actually see gps
and there are so many telephone
appointments
um being carried out and
i i fear that that there are going to be
um mountain problems within
you know sort of that area as time goes
by
and it is something that you know i
would like us to look into
yeah i i absolutely agree um i think
we've had that raised by other members
as well so that's definitely something
that we
do need to consider just to say we did
have i think we had the clinical lead
for the ccg
with us not very long ago so perhaps it
would be a good time to invite him back
uh just for an update and perhaps
members can share their concerns
because i think it is a shared concern
for councillors across the board i think
we've all
heard from residents who are concerned
about accessing a gp and
who actually want a face-to-face
appointment now rather than um
over the internet so um if members are
happy we'll
definitely be scheduling that into our
work programme
um fabio did you want to say something
oh yes sure uh
through your chair the uh the item is
due to come back
this municipal year um about the
accessibility of primary care services
it was one of our resolution last year
yes so perhaps maybe given the concern
that has mounted since we last saw
the clinical lead perhaps we can bring
that forward as one of our main
priorities
any other issues that members would like
us to raise and also heather from
healthwatch um you produced some really
excellent reports
was there anything that you would like
us to particularly bring to committee
i can't see heather anymore i'm not sure
she's still um
yeah yeah and i've looked through your
um
um of suggestions and there's quite a
lot on there that actually
healthwatch is looking at uh currently
so um i've been asked to go on to
a group looking at some cross-border
issues um and
we're currently well within the next two
to three weeks
we're producing a report on inequalities
and with apologies to rob it is in i'm
afraid in the north of the
north of the county um we've
been looking at some of the public's
priorities about
what how they want to see services
uh and and we've produced
um a combined gm report on
uh covert 19 um and some of the lessons
that have been learned we've also
produced um
a gm wide report on dentistry
and there are lots and lots of concerns
that
people are being asked to go privately
rather than having nhs dentists and
indeed in some parts of the country you
simply can't get
an nhs dentist so i was pleased to see
that with the development of the
integrated care system
um that in fact dentistry and and
and dental advice and
um involvement is part of the work of
the
integrated care system so that will be
a step in the right direction because we
sometimes struggle to get feedback
from the local committee there um
and uh so from that you'll see
that um there's quite a bit of stuff
that we are currently doing
uh which really is um pretty much in
line
with some of the um uh the topics that
you've got on your list
and topics that are not on your list
that we have
uh put down for um our work programme
for this next year um our
children's services um and
mental health as well as
finalizing work on inequalities and also
looking at uh waiting lists for elective
procedures
so there is some commonality between the
two
and if you recall when the cqc came in
and did a system
two or three years ago what they wanted
to ensure was that health watch and
health scrutiny
were working closely together and trying
to share
uh priorities and uh and try and
coordinate the work in some way
so it was quite pleasing to see um some
of the topics that members have
suggested
heather that is really useful and i
think you have raised um you know some
really
serious and important um topics that i'm
sure
uh health scrutiny committee would want
to take forward
and of the one of the topics that um
heather has mentioned
um the committee have very strong
feelings about what we would like to
consider and perhaps consider imminently
rather than
um leave it a little while fabulous did
you want to say did you want to say
something
uh yes uh chair thank you again through
you
um it's really like my uh
my certain work here to remind members
that when we bring uh
items to the attention of the health
scrutiny committee
uh we let's say members
should ask why we're bringing those
items what the scrutiny committee what
kind of
input the scrutiny committee can can
you know uh deliver and what we're
trying to achieve
again as a scrutiny committee a war at
the value
uh that is in in in for the scrutiny to
bring
those those items to uh its attention
so that's just obviously because we're
conscious also for
um officers and in the work we
um they undertake thank you
yeah thanks thank you fabially yes and
absolutely i mean
if we can't add value then obviously we
don't have a role so
clearly when we bring these topics to
committee we
are looking to scrutinize and hopefully
improve and um add suggestions and
make changes uh for the better so
absolutely so
bearing that advice from fabiola in mind
from the things that have been raised do
members feel very strongly what they
would like to see
coming forward sooner rather than later
and council courtney has put in the chat
and that he would like to include the gp
topics
particularly about replacing gps who are
retired we do know that
there's an issue with recruitment of gps
isn't there so
and again that is an issue within the
bow we know that gps are retiring across
the borough
and practices are closing so and that is
something that we can definitely put
into
and the mix when we next think about our
our agenda
and counselor chilton you wanted to say
something oh i'm sorry i'm counselor
back then
i'm sorry some people have dropped off
my screen so it's hard to see so
yeah so if it's council blackburn first
and then councilor chilton
and then i didn't put my hand down after
i spoke last time i've just done it now
thank you oh okay fine councillor
chilton
yeah just a note of caution uh well
comment really
i hope we can work very closely with
healthwatch because
um a we don't want necessarily to
duplicate the same work that they're
doing
um because that's a waste of everyone's
time but we
also there may be quantitative
information that we can get that they
may not have access to
and similarly there will be some
qualitative information that they have
access to
that we might not get as readily so i
hope we can
work together with them on that and just
in terms of the work programme
i think um access to elective um
treatments at the moment is is causing
major issues
everywhere and so that could do with
looking at
and actually and what council actually
knows i mean doesn't affect my work but
i can imagine cross-border issues can be
a massive headache
so that those two might be worth looking
at thanks yes
i agree i mean it's cross-border issues
for myself as well in my ward too i mean
i think everybody
will have residents who've had a
manchester gp and just kept them
despite the fact they moved so it is an
issue and i think that's been brought up
quite a few times and definitely
something that we should address uh
counselor weston
just following on from um heather's
comments
um we did start last year pre-pandemic
in children's scrutiny looking at cams
or healthy young minds as it is now so
that's something
which may tie in with the mental health
work that's being done
and we're we are hoping to pick that up
and
following um councillor whitman's um
presentation
child poverty is something else that um
we think we'd like to look at next year
when we set our work programme
um so it may be something that could
cross both both scrutiny committees or
all scrutiny committees it's
they are really all encompassing issues
aren't there that affects
everybody so uh yeah just uh a comment
there
okay fantastic so um fabian i know
you'll be noting down
all of these issues and obviously when
um sophie and myself next consider the
agenda
then we will definitely be thinking how
we can prioritize these issues
is there anything else anyone would like
us to consider
as well i mean we have had some
suggestions and some concerns raised
over other issues that we have noted
um for example um mental health
the mental health impacts of applying
for pip
assessments and that's certainly
something i've experienced with one of
my residents and
i think it is a generality that it's an
extremely stressful
difficult situation perhaps we could
look at that so against need to go in
into the mix of things but
is there anything else members would
like to raise you can always email of
course fabiola
in the meanwhile because you know not
everything comes to mind now so
if you think of something that is
important you feel we can make a
difference with
then please do email i'll be able in the
meantime but
just looking around no one else has put
anything in the chat and oh counselor
taylor
i think just to comment counselor
barclay as well that um
some of the pieces of work will perhaps
um traverse the whole of the municipal
yeah but
i think as we've done in the past some
of them have been quite short pieces of
work haven't they
you know that we can maybe just address
over the course of a meeting or we can
have a little subgroup
and that's aside from this meeting so
you know sometimes there are some sort
of quite
easy wins almost aren't the really i
mean just thinking of the piece of work
that
we did just looking at gp provisioning
doesn't so
um i would encourage members to think of
maybe things that are maybe
a little bit more long-term but also
maybe some um
shorter um pieces of work that we can
maybe um
implement uh quite quite quickly and
readily but still get
some valuable outcomes from those as
well really
um thank you
yeah thank you thank you councillor
today that's really useful and yes so of
course please
you know share any any thoughts with
fabiola and when we meet next we will
definitely
incorporate things as best we can to
cover all these issues and obviously
a mix of short and long-term work
any any other comments from members
no okay well perhaps do you feel we have
enough there
uh fabiola to develop the work program
going forward yes okay
fantastic okay so um just uh moving on
to final items now the agenda so
uh a generalized antenna is urgent
business i don't have any
i don't think you have any fabiola name
and then um
item eleven a generation eleven is the
exclusive resolution which is not
applicable now so just leave me to say
thank you so so much to all our members
for coming this evening
and some of the fantastic questioning
thank you to officers
and a huge thank you to fabiola of
course who supports supports the
committee amazingly
and just to say thank you all for coming
and feel